who ruined the most takes Hobbs or sha
it couldn't have been Hobbs his banner
straw for sure so you know follow the
natural conclusion there got it um who
is most likely to get it on the first
take
Hobbs our Shah again a guy got his hand
in hand right okay
who has more hair Hobbs our Shah he's
got the body here I think Polynesians we
don't we're not too much we don't need
that God who's faster leaving their
trailer Hobbs our Shah nobody wins this
one uh-oh just a guess yeah I can't
really say they're very very
doesn't have to be that have to be eaten
like God profession we're switching into
a new thing um who wins in a fight Hobbs
in Shaw or Jason Bourne
Hobbs and sure who wins in a fight Hobbs
in Shaw or Deadpool Hopson Shaw uh who
Hobson shot or John wick I was a jock a
mana guy Hobbs in Shaw or John McClane
okay I'm gonna get one Hobbs and Shaw or
the Terminator observing he jabs every
time he never wins terminated her name
ever wins
Hobson Shaw all right Hobson show okay
so that's on II uh hubs and Shaw or
Thanos okay Hobbs and Shaw or Chev
Chelios from crank short can take care
yeah he's actually in the Hobbs and Shaw
world balanced diet that was the first
one that Statham actually paused and
said wait a minute
chef Kelly Hobson shot or Bruce Lee oh
good person come on don't don't use
right you can't do that I am doing that
because eventually I'm gonna cross over
where you will admit that someone can
beat that someone can win
so what can Bruce beat Hobbs in Shaw
can't even go to I can't answer that
question I'm tapping out she's had me
out there huh I'm just for the sake of
the street Hobbs and Shaw okay dirty
about that that was gross sorry Hobbs in
Shaw or Ripley in aliens Sigourney
Weaver I mean she destroys lovesick now
that's my the family we're on Avatar
together so I was like yes right come
miss with that for the sake of cliffy
here we'll go with her see you women win
yes that was the first one where Dwayne
crosstalk okay fair enough now Hobbs and
Shaw or Sarah Connor in Terminator 2
yeah but I feel like one of our guy
either Hobbs or shawl is gonna work the
magic you know what I mean well they're
gonna double-team right it's like two of
them at the same time they're like
smashing you're like doing that kind of
thing that's pretty odd I'm gonna show
this okay Hobbs in Shaw or rocky with
the rocky theme music playing in the
scene Z in Russia where where's the
location it's rocky for its it's before
the Drago fight after he's trained for
the Drago fight man so he's in good
shape you just had to say that Todd's in
Java
ja you almost had us there in good shape
he's right over there man